can you wrote about whether or not
Hillary Clinton can reassemble the Obama
coalition it was in South Carolina where
she began to lose the black vote how
does she recapture it this time around
well you know we're talking about going
back to the Democratic primary of 2008
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama were
basically breaking even with
african-american voters than Barack
Obama has his breakout victory in Iowa a
proof of concept to african-american
voters that he can actually win and then
in South Carolina a couple weeks later
barack obama gets ninety percent of the
african-american vote and has an
overwhelming victory in South Carolina
so I think actually african-americans
are a firewall for Clinton in the
Democratic primary which does not look
to be particularly competitive now but
as you go to the general election
getting african-american voters out is
crucial for her general election
prospects as well you know we used to
refer to Bill Clinton as the first
african-american president is that
legacy his relationship with the back
black community important for her
election now you know I think so I mean
you sort of smile when you say about
Bill Clinton is the first
african-american president but then we
had the first african-american president
in Barack Obama and what we saw with
that in terms of the performance of
african-americans in the electorate
african-american turnout was the highest
ever african-americans comprised the
highest proportion of the electorate and
they're always loyalty to Democrats they
were phenomenally loyal to Democrats so
there was some ill will in 2008 but I
think that's mostly forgotten but the
question is can the Democrats turnout
african-americans when Barack Obama is
not at the top of the ticket can to take
that further in the general election do
you see a cogent strategy by anybody on
the other side to gain Latino or gain
black votes well not you know not not so
far and and and the simple eighth grade
algebra word problem makes it very
challenging for Republicans if they do
not do better with Hispanics and better
with african-american voters but when I
started writing that piece a couple days
ago I really was focusing on Hispanics
but then when I got into the
numbers what was really clear to me yeah
Latinos are important but they generally
live in states that aren't competitive
New York Texas California and really
keep your eye on african-americans as we
go forward here ken is this a new move
for Hillary Clinton has she taken up the
subject of race before or can we look at
what happened yesterday her speech in
Ferguson is that a purely political move
no I don't think it's a purely political
move I mean you look at you look at her
history and these are these are big
issues she's been involved in and I'm
not sure when this particular event was
scheduled and we've obviously had you
know incredibly tragic and now
fast-moving events in in the last week
so I think she can talk to
african-americans I don't think there's
lingering bitterness from 2008 it's not
so much i think that African Americans
would be against Hillary Clinton but how
do you recreate that phenomenal
performance that Barack Obama had
because for every percent of
african-american vote additional in the
electorate that's almost a one to one
additional percent for Democrats can you
mention a Latino voters not in key
states very quickly here does a black
vote matter in Ohio sure the black vote
matters in Ohio it's about thirteen
fourteen percent of the electorate but
the Democrats are getting 95 96 percent
of that vote and so in that way the
Democrats can lose white voters almost
60 40 and still win a state like Ohio
can you make the point that in 2012 to
turnout among african-americans was the
highest among the four groups what is
their main concern right now as we head
towards the elections well I think it I
think African Americans care about the
economy and care about jobs and I think
all the data shows that over the last
eight years and the economic recovery
african-americans have not done as well
as everyone else so there's certainly
these cogent racial issues that are
going on now they care about the issues
that everyone cares about economy jobs
Ken Goldstein in Washington from
Bloomberg during the early math on next
year's election